ja wenn der intendant begrüße sie recht
herzlich zum pressing hier im
robert-koch-institut heute am 13 märz
begrüßen auch diejenigen die über
internet oder fernsehen zu schauen oder
zu hören
heute ist professor lothar wieder ihr
gesprächspartner der präsident des
robert koch-instituts der wie üblich
eine kurze einschätzung der lage geben
wird und danach fragen zur verfügung
steht und im anschluss ist wie gewohnt
ein kurzes sammle statement im foyer
noch möglich wieder würden morgen
zusammen hier im hörsaal und draußen die
zuschauer euch begrüßte sie alle sehr
herzlich
am 13 märz 2020 wie immer gebe ich
zunächst einen kurzen überblick über die
weltweite situation um mich dann aber
vor allem natürlich der deutschen lage
zu widmen wie erwartbar steigen die
fallzahlen weltweit an und wir haben es
mit einer pandemie zu tun
und dieser anstieg der zahlen denen
müssen wir natürlich auch noch in den
nächsten wochen erwarten wie lange diese
zahl noch ansteigen wissen wenn ich aber
es ist wie gesagt eine pandemie die uns
noch eine lange zeit beschäftigen wird
wenn wir auf die zahlen insgesamt
schauen weltweit dann haben wir heute an
offiziell gemeldeten zahlen 128.000 das
sind 6 also knapp 7000 mehr als gestern
bislang wurde berichtet von 4.700 13
todesfälle in china nehmen die zahlen ab
das wurde auch mehrfach bereits
vermeldet und außerhalb von chinas
nehmen die zahlen zu inzwischen sind 114
länder betroffen das heißt also in 114
ländern ist dieses virus bei patienten
nachgewiesen worden
das heißt das sind die offiziell
bestätigen fälle die uns bekannt sind
das sind insgesamt 47.000 fälle und seit
gestern sind auch da knapp 7000
dazugekommen sie sehen also daran dass
die fälle die wir nun immer offiziell
melden momentan zumindest hauptsächlich
außerhalb von chinas auftreten
unter diesen 47.000 gemeldeten fällen
zum heutigen zeiten
hier wissen wir davon dass 1542 personen
an der krone virus infektion verstorben
sind
es gibt rund 1300 schwere
krankheitsverläufe das heißt das sind
patienten die schwere lungenentzündungen
an schweren lungenentzündungen leiden
und eben in den meisten fällen bad mit
beratungspflicht ich geworden sind kurz
ins leere europäische umfeld sicher
kennen sie das geschehen in italien hier
haben wir mit dem standpunkt heute
morgen 12 1462 fälle
die haben um ein viertel ungefähr
zugenommen seit gestern und in italien
wurden bereits 827 todesfälle vermeldet
in frankreich haben wir ebenfalls eine
zunahme rund 2200 fälle ebenfalls in
spanien da sind das heute 2270 fälle in
beiden ländern in frankreich sind es 48
todesfälle und in spanien bislang 55
todesfälle also eine sehr dynamische
situation zunahme von fällen
selbstverständlich auch leider zunahme
von todesfällen
so wie wir das in deutschland auch
erwarten müssen schauen wir nach
deutschland
der status sieht so aus momentan es ist
wie gesagt immer eine momentane
situation die sehr dynamisch ist die
sich jeden tag ändert und ich werde
ihnen dazu gleich noch einfach sagen zu
den meldezahlen die die in der zukunft
vom rk ii vermeldet werden es gibt eine
kleine änderung in der systematik nur
dass sie das begreifen herrscher hatte
das gestern auch schon angesprochen
in deutschland 2369 fälle das sind rund
zehn prozent mehr also eine starke
zunahme als gestern und bislang ist uns
bekannt dass in deutschland sechs
menschen dieser krankheit an dieser
krankheit verstorben sind
wenn wir uns deutschland etwas genauer
anschauen
der stand gestern abend
im insgesamt 2390 die fälle wie gesagt
und das hauptgeschehen also von der
anzahl der fälle zumindest die die
höchste anzahl haben wir nach wie vor in
nordrhein-westfalen momentan 688 war dem
württemberg 454 und bayern 500 das sind
so die bundesländer wo wir die höchsten
reihen fallzahlen haben wenn wir das auf
die bevölkerung betrachten dann ist das
etwas anders
in nordrhein westfalen haben wir
ungefähr 3,8 pro 100.000 einwohner
wir müssen das thema beziehen auf die
einwohnerzahl und zum beispiel im
bundesland sachsen sind es zurzeit 0,74
pro 100.000 einwohner aber ich möchte
immer wieder betonen dass das momentane
zahlen sind die sich jeden tag ändern
und jeden tag in jedem bundesland sich
verschieben werden und anders sein
werden
ich denke das wichtigste was verstanden
werden muss ist dass diese epidemie die
durch unser land geht eben nicht einfach
gleichmäßig von einer himmelsrichtung in
die andere sich ausweitet sondern
wirklich auch sehr sehr ähnlich wie wir
das von der gruppe ja seit jahrzehnten
kennen dass es immer wieder regionale
vorgegeben wird wo bestimmte zahlen
ansteigen wo ausbrüche eingedämmt werden
können wo man die kontakte nach
verfolgung noch in bestimmten
landkreisen schafft oder auch nicht also
ein sehr dynamisches geschehen was uns
über viele wochen begleiten wird und wo
wir immer wieder unterschiedliche
tendenzen und ergebnisse haben werden
zu den zahlen und zu einem aspekt den
ich heute ein wenig näher beleuchten
möchte
wir haben in deutschland 2369 labor
bestätigte fälle das hatte ihm
mitgeteilt das ist die zahl die wir
kennen
nun wissen sie dass es in deutschland
und wie in jedem anderen land natürlich
auch einen offiziellen meldeweg gibt
offiziell werden die zahlen von den
gesundheitsämtern an das robert koch
institut gemeldet das funktioniert über
eine software die den gesundheitsämtern
zur verfügung steht
aber selbstverständlich müssen die
gesundheitsämter das eintragen
das muss ja dann am anfang händisch
eingetragen werden das kann ja gar nicht
anders sein das heißt also zwischen den
labor bestätigten fällen und den fällen
die eben offiziell eingetragenen gibt es
immer eine kleine
die sind ein wenig geringer die zahlen
die von den gesundheitsämtern
eingetragen werden das heißt von diesen
2300 603 169 fällen sind bislang 8000
entschuldigung 1892 fälle aus 16
bundesländern übermittelt worden
sie sehen also da klafft eine gewisse
lücke das ist ein zeitverzug teilweise
von drei vier tagen nur dass sie das
verstehen wir werden in der zukunft
einfach nicht mehr jeden dieser fälle
validiert nachvollziehen können wir
haben bisher sehr viel aufwand darauf
getrieben jeden einzelnen fall zu prüfen
nachzuprüfen das tun wir natürlich
weiter wir können das mit der
zunehmenden zahl einfach nicht mehr
leisten wenn wir demnächst 10.000 fälle
haben oder wie viel wie auch immer haben
werden können sie verstehen dass wir
nicht jeden einzelnen fall nochmal
validiert nachvollziehen können das
heißt wir werden uns zukünftig nur noch
auf die offiziellen meldezahlen
beschränken weil wir das einfach nicht
mehr leisten können und dann nicht dass
dann jemand den eindruck hat die
fallzahl nehmen ab in deutschland
sondern es ist längst einfach damit
zusammen dass wir die erfassung der
zahlen etwas ändern
in deutschland ist es so dass die person
die betroffen sind die altersspanne
zwischen null und 89 jahren
ich hatte ihn immer vermittelt dass
dieses virus eben wirklich jeden
infizieren kann völlig unabhängig vom
alter
aber der unterschied ist eben der der
ausgang der schweregrad der infektion
mit zunehmendem alter insbesondere ab 50
vor allen dingen aber auch 60 mit
zunehmendem alter und grundkrankheiten
wird didi didi dieser die
wahrscheinlichkeit oder das risiko dass
personen schwerer erkranken einfach
höher
das heißt nicht dass auch nicht junge
einzelne schwer erkranken können aber
das risiko steigt einfach immer größer
und wir haben eben weil den alten und
hochaltrigen die höchste risikogruppe
doch müssen wir mit den meisten schwer
verlaufen fällen rechnen und eben auch
mit den entsprechenden todesfällen bei
uns in deutschland ist es auch so
bislang dass mehr männer betroffen sind
von den meldezahlen sind 1075 männer und
816 weiblich also 75 prozent männlich 53
prozent das ist einfach nur ein
zwischenstand das sehen wir in vielen
ländern
warum das so ist können wir uns nicht
erklären das wird dann vielleicht nach
der epidemie irgendwann mal wissen
aber das ist einfach bislang eine
beobachtung so den melde verzug
den hatte ich ihnen schon vermittelt ja
das heißt also wir werden ab jetzt
natürlich jeden tag weiter im internet
aktualisiert was wir tun werden und zwar
ich glaube bis nächste woche
ich glaube dass nächste woche werden wir
zunächst mal beide zahlen noch ihn zur
verfügung stellen und dann ab nächster
woche eben nur noch die eine zahl die
eben bestätigt ist über unser
elektronisches system also bitte dass
sie diese leichte differenz verstehen
und das nicht als eine trendwende etwa
verstehen wollen oder so interpretieren
das wäre ein missverständnis
wir werden immer die zahlen jeden tag im
internet aktualisieren und zwar immer am
späten nachmittag frühen abend also
spätestens 17 18 uhr werden sie die
jeweils aktuellen zahlen des tages dann
auf unseren webseiten finden der
entscheidende vorteil von diesem
meldezahlen offiziell ist halt der dass
wir da natürlich auch noch zusätzlich
informationen bereitgestellt bekommen
zum beispiel das alter oder das
geschlecht oder den erkrankungsbeginn
das ist wichtig die zahl alleine sind ja
wirklich nur zahlen von den gemeldeten
aber mit den ganzen dahinter liegenden
epidemiologischen daten können wir
natürlich viel stärker aussagen treffen
über das geschehen wie welche
altersgruppen sind betroffen ist das so
wie wir das erwartet und so weiter die
zahlen alleine sind eben nur
momentaufnahmen wobei jeder wissen muss
dass diese zahlen eben nicht die waren
an zahlen in jedem land betreffen
sondern es gibt natürlich immer eine
gewisse dunkelziffer das muss uns auch
klar sein es gibt immer mehr fälle als
offiziell gemeldet lassen sie mich auch
nochmal zur krankheit folgendes sagen
alles was wir bisher aus von dieser
krankheit gelernt haben die war wirklich
erst seit wenigen wochen kennen ist das
rund vier von fünf menschen die mit dem
virus infiziert werden nur leichte
symptome haben oder gar keine sind
thoma also vier von fünf wird an denen
wird diese krankheit mehr oder weniger
spurlos vorbeigehen
sie haben wirklich vielleicht nur
leichten schnupfen symptome manche
werden eben gar keine symptome haben das
liegt daran dass es eigentlich gar kein
erreger gibt ganz ganz persönlich kenne
nur eine regel
das ist das maul und klauenseuche virus
bei wiederkäuern dass bei jedem tier das
infiziert wird auch eine klinische
symptomatik macht aber das gibt es die
meisten erreger machen das eben nicht
sondern viele werden einfach nur
infiziert merken es gar nicht bilden
aber dann eine immunität aus das ist der
grund dass eben auch jede epidemien und
pandemien irgendwann mal zum stoppen
kommt weil einfach viele menschen dann
in dem falle immunität also vier von
fünf die in deutschland infiziert werden
das zeigt sich in vielen ländern haben
leichte symptomatik das ist gut so die
sind immun und werden dann dazu
beitragen dass die epidemie langsamer
verläuft aber eben einer von fünf ist
eben ein patient bei dem es schwerer
verläuft und je nach altersstufe und
riesige gruppe sind dann die verläufe
ihm sehr schwer oder auch tödlich das
ist wichtig zu verstehen also vier von
fünf werden mit dieser infektion leicht
umgehen können hoffen wir dass das für
viele von uns eben dann zutrifft was tun
wir was müssen wir tun um in unserem
land uns optimal vorzuhalten das ist
diese trias über die wir auch seit
vielen wochen eigentlich sprechen
erstens verlangsamung also nach wie vor
kontakt nachverfolgung eindämmung
gesundheitsämter müssen versuchen
personen die identifiziert worden als
infiziert diese person in quarantäne zu
stecken wenn es irgendwie geht und dann
führt zu sorgen dass diese menschen eben
keine weiteren anstecken
das wird natürlich nicht immer gelingen
aber ihr häufiger das gelingt desto
langsamer wird die epidemie laufen das
ist das system das werden wir auch
kontinuierlich weiter betreiben wir
werden in diesem land nach aller
voraussicht irgendwann das nicht mehr
schaffen weil das einfach zu viele fälle
sind aber wir werden es trotzdem immer
weiter versuchen denn jeden fall den wir
aus dem infektionsgeschehen herausnehmen
können ist ein fall der wenige andere
ansteckt also es ist der verlangsamung
aspekt der zweite aspekt ist der wir
wollen versuchen mit allen uns zur
verfügung stehenden mitteln diese wo wir
diese epidemische kurve abzuflachen die
basispreise zu machen um warum wir
wollen dass eben möglichst viele von den
schwer erkrankten nicht gleichzeitig im
gesundheitssystem auftauchen dort
behandelt werden müssten krankenhäuser
je weniger schwer kranke je weniger
beratungspflicht patienten zum selben
zeitpunkt karten häuser aufsuchen oder
beziehungsweise im krankenhaus behandelt
werden müssen desto größer ist die
chance dass es gelingt sie alle zu
behandeln das ist der punkt der zweite
punkt ist der erfolgt ganz einfach da
raus wir müssen auf der anderen seite
alles andere beschleunigen also alles
was die kapazitäten im krankenhaus
erhöht alles was dazu führt dass
eingriffe in krankenhäusern die nicht
zwingend notwendig sind abgesagt werden
um im krankenhaus die bettenkapazität zu
erhöhen für schwer kranke patienten für
beatmungspatienten alles was wir tun
können um das zu erhöhen muss
beschleunigt werden da sind viele
maßnahmen die vielen von ihnen bekannt
sind dort sehr sehr viel getan
und hier ist mein appell an die
krankenhäuser die betreiber von
krankenhäusern dass sie ihre
krankenhäuser darauf einstellen die
wissen wie das geht das ist kein
hexenwerk das ist ein krisenplan das
sind professionelle betreiber ärzte
pflege engagierte menschen die unseren
gesellschaftlichen tun sehr sehr vieles
ergeben mit denen muss man solidarität
haben aber die müssen es eben auch tun
die entsprechende betreiber und alle
anreize dafür dass das auch getan wird
die werden gesetzt und der dritte aspekt
ist auch ein ganz wichtiger den wir auch
seit vielen wochen immer wieder
ansprechen und der auch in den blick
genommen wollen muss die verlangsamung
geschieht natürlich dadurch dass er zum
beispiel großveranstaltung ab sagen dass
wir bestimmte das war von uns allen
erwarten dass wir bestimmte
versammlungen vielleicht gar nicht mehr
abhalten bzw
nicht mehr hingehen um dieses geschehen
hat nicht zu beschleunigen
aber natürlich gibt es veranstaltungen
die müssen einfach stattfinden es muss
ja ein öffentliches leben stattfinden es
müssen bestimmte dinge getan werden und
jeder von uns möge einfach darüber
nachdenken was er noch tun muss wo er
hingehen muss oder wo es vorher nicht
vielleicht die er oder sie und dann gilt
es eben jetzt diese sogenannte
schutzbedürftigen menschen in unserem
land zu schützen die hochaltrigen die
chronisch kranken
lassen sie uns alles dafür tun dass
diese menschen mit menschen geschützt
werden und auch da gibt es viele ideen
konzepte wir selber haben ja dokumente
auf unserer website eingestellt die ich
bitte alle zu lesen und sich gedanken
machen wie sie das in ihrem eigenen
umfeld machen können da ist
nachbarschaft sich hilfe gefragt und so
weiter und so fort ich weiß dass es da
ganz viele ideen gibt und ich weiß auch
dass das viele von den mitmenschen das
auch machen werden und darum bin ich
auch sehr optimistisch dass vieles
abgefedert wird zum schluss noch eine
noch eine vom meldung kurz vielleicht
nur an einen der vielen maßnahmen die in
deutschland gefahren wenn an der wir an
dieser maßnahme sind wir auch beteiligt
ich sagte ja es ist sehr sehr wichtig
dass wir es schaffen die die beatmungs
plätze so gesprochen in krankenhäusern
möglichst so hoch wie möglich zu halten
und zu steigern
aber wenn sie sich vorstellen dass eben
sehr viele menschen zu einem gleichen
zeitpunkt in einem bestimmten
krankenhaus behandelt werden müssen dann
ist es nicht auszuschließen das ist eben
vielleicht gar nicht genügend beatmungs
plätze geben wird und dann ist es
natürlich sehr wichtig dass man
strategisch vor denkt welches
krankenhaus in der nähe hat dennoch
beatmungs plätze es geht um
strategisches patientenmanagement wie
wir das so nennen
und wir haben zusammen mit der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin und der
deutschen krankenhausgesellschaft ein
tool entwickelt und werkzeugen
entwickelt eine art in verfassungssystem
so dass man weiß wo welche krankenhäuser
noch kapazitäten oder nicht das ist sehr
wichtig für die krankenhäuser dass sie
sich dort wirklich gut absprechen und
das natürlich auch notdienste
notfallaufnahmen und so weiter darauf
vorbereitet sind und die patienten eben
zu den richtigen stellen gefahren werden
für den fall dass eben diese kapazität
limits erreicht werden wir sagen das ja
schon seit langem wir
gehen davon aus dass es ein stresstest
wird für unser land für viele
krankenhäuser
aber wir wollen eben so viel wie möglich
dafür tun dass das gut organisiert
geregelt wird das möglich die
kapazitäten optimal genutzt werden und
das ist die wirklich die die positive
nachricht eben
wir haben zum glück sehr früh diese
epidemie in unserem land erkannt und
zwar nicht nur finden aufgrund der test
und wir mal sehr viele testung das ist
ein großer vorteil unserem land wir
haben dadurch viele ergebnis von testung
sondern eben auch weil wir am
robert-koch-institut einige werkzeuge
haben mit denen wir die krankheitslast
in der bevölkerung an
atemwegsinfektionen und an einer
lungenentzündung messen können mit
bestimmten werkzeuge tools die wir für
unsere fans über für uns so genannte
überwachung fahren und zwar seit vielen
jahren das sind verschiedene werkzeuge
sind alle im wochenbericht influenza
genannt wir wissen zum beispiel wie
viele menschen schwer kranke
lungenentzündung patienten in deutschen
krankenhäusern liegen da haben wir einen
bestimmten einen blick wir wissen über
grippe web einen city sind silence
ansatz also wo menschen sich selber
registrieren können ihre eigene symptome
eingeben können haben wir einen blick
darauf wie hoch die last ist von
infektionskrankheiten von
atemwegsinfektionen
wir haben ein zentrales thema rund 6 700
praxen in deutschland proben einschicken
regelmäßig also 100 davon schicken
regelmäßig proben an aber es sind
insgesamt 67 und praxen
dadurch wissen wir welche viren
nachgewiesen werden in diesen einzelnen
praxen haben überblick wo die viren
diese werkzeuge die wir etabliert haben
wir die letzten jahre
die sind sehr robust sehr aussagefähig
und wir können sie natürlich auch nutzen
um den anstieg von atemwegserkrankungen
zu sehen die mit corona zusammenhängen
und darum können wir ziemlich großen
überzeugung sagen dass wir am anfang
dieser epidemie stehen und darum können
wir diese maßnahme alle noch in die wege
leiten und die vordere zum schluss noch
mal auf alle diese entscheidungsträger
das sind die landräte und die
bürgermeister das sind die entscheider
in den orten wie mit den kranken
umgegangen wird auf weisung oder auf
beziehungsweise auf
hinweise von den gesundheitsämtern und
diejenigen die für die krankenhäuser
verantwortlich sind bitte bereiten sich
auf diese epidemie weit davor diese
krise die auf uns zukommt können wir
optimal managen wenn alle ihre
ressourcen optimal koordiniert einsetzen
dankeschön ihre fragen es gibt ja so
eine zahl
das 60 bis 70 prozent der bevölkerung
sich infiziert wo kommt sie her
ja das ist eine zahl die das ist so was
wie das einmaleins der
infektionsepidemiologie dass wenn man
ein pandemische virus hat also ein virus
das verschiedene eigenschaften hat es
wird relativ leicht übertragen
und ich kann sagen generell ein
krankheitserreger liebers muss nicht nur
ein virus sein es kann ja auch ein
bakterium sind also wenn ein
krankheitserreger leichter übertragbar
ist also relativ rasch von einem
menschen auf den anderen übertragen wird
und auch noch die eigenschaft hat dass
er nicht nur übertragen wird sondern
dass er dann auch doch zu krankheiten
führt das ist eine eine voraussetzung
das zweite ist dieses virus ist in der
bevölkerung also in der menschlichen
also bei den menschen auf diesem globus
ein völlig unbekanntes virus es gibt
keine immunität dagegen das ist also ein
nicht bekanntes virus dann dann ist es
so dass dieses und wendet sich dann eben
über tröpfcheninfektion überträgt wie
weit bei lungenerkrankungen das auf der
fall ist ja und wenn es dann keinen
impfstoff gibt und kein therapeutikum
gibt dann kann dieses virus sich eben
aus brighton in einer population und
dann ist es biologisch völlig
nachvollziehbar dass das immer 60 bis 70
prozent der menschen sein werden warum
sind es 60 bis 70 prozent es ist ein
gewisser zeitraum ich sagte gerade viele
menschen werden infizierte merken ist
vielleicht gar nicht vier von fünf kam
leicht symptome die venen dann immun das
heißt also es gibt verschiedene wellen
in der regel
und da gibt es immer ein teil von ihm
davon nicht immun und das spielt sich
ein biologisches gleichgewicht an das
liegt immer so bei 60 70 prozent das
wird bei diesem virus auch nicht anders
sein das ist völlig normal
das kann man sich statistisch berechnen
das sind das ist so eine grundlage von
infektions epidemiologischen kenntnissen
so und das ist aber eben nur so wenn man
keine werkzeuge hat mit dem man dagegen
vorgehen kann ein impfstoff zum beispiel
wenn wir einen impfstoff hätten könnten
wir das natürlich verhindern wir haben
aber keinen stoff dh der impfstoff wirkt
irgendwann im nächsten jahr einsetzbar
sein und darum wissen wir dass wir gegen
dieses virus eben momentan mit den
klassischen methoden vorgehen können wir
können es verlangsamt um das
gesundheitssystem dass das sehr
leistungsfähig dass wir haben optimal
nutzen zu können
und also das ist einfach der faktor der
punkt ist jetzt die frage ist wie lange
dauert das ja wann sind diese 60 bis 70
prozent infiziert das wissen wir eben
nicht das sind spekulationen man kann
das auch modellieren
aber die modelle haben alle extreme
fehlerquote man hat ja mal an namen die
man die modelle gibt also viele von uns
rechnen damit dass es vielleicht eins
vielleicht zwei jahre lang dauern wird
bis das geschehen ist aber das wird so
kommen und mehr kann ich dazu auch nicht
sagen
sie sagten einer von fünf erkrankt
schwer heißt schwer erkrankt automatisch
beatmung nein nein eine abstufung ja
klar gibt es ab stufe na ja also das
[Musik]
noch mal da sind alles zahlen die
natürlich nicht wirklich belastbar sind
ja aber nach nach dem was wir heute
wissen
nehmen wir eine zahlen vielleicht fünf
prozent dass die wirklich schwer krank
sind vielleicht beatmet werden müssen
das ist etwa eine größenordnung die aber
natürlich fehlt aber in dieser
größenordnung muss wir damit rechnen
dass etwa fünf prozent wirklich so
schwer erkranken dass sie beatmet werden
ja na klar im schnitt ein guter punkt
den die frau glas moment also der
registrierten erkrankungen ganz genommen
und so werden viele nichtregistrierte
haben sie auch eine quote wie viele
leute schon wieder genesen sind
es gibt zahlen dazu die stehen auch auf
dem dashboard von von der johns hopkins
haben
kopf ich kann sie nicht genau sagen aber
sind natürlich sehr viele chinesen sind
klar und ich sage es noch mal ganz ganz
viele wissen wir ja gar nicht dass sie
infiziert waren sie hatten gar keine
symptome sie waren irgendwo im
meldewesen aufgetaucht und die zellen ja
auch zu diesen 60 bis 70 prozent die wir
aber nicht wissen
aber diese eben geben wird und das ist
auch gut zu e-mails von denen gibt desto
besser ist es natürlich
sie haben gesagt 2369 kritisiert wenn
ich sage jetzt mal auf 60% vorsichtig
rechnet das heißt 50 millionen deutsche
werden sich anstecken
ja das ist so eine zahl von der wahl
ausgehen müssen im raum von von 12
jahren sagen wir wissen es nicht genau
wie gegen millionenschwere nein also
nochmal wir reden davon dass war von den
von den von den fällen die registriert
sind das davon etwa fünf prozent
wirklich schwer krank werden ja und wie
wir haben eine gewisse dunkelziffer bei
der registrierung also das sind alles
zahlenspiele die was ich ihnen sagen
will ist folgendes wir müssen eben
leider davon ausgehen dass es teilweise
so viele werden dass das kapazität des
gesundheitssystems nicht mehr ausreicht
um sie zu versorgen
das ist die die sorge die wir haben das
der grund warum es verlangsamt
wir können alle möglichen zahlen spiele
machen wir werden das gesundheitssystem
optimal einstellen müssen um die eine
versorgung zu können aber in deutschland
kommt zeitverzögert auch was jetzt schon
in italien sich andeutet nun wir hoffen
dass nicht ja ich sage es nochmal wir
können das nicht ausschließen wir können
das nicht ausschließen dass es so ist
also was in italien ist es für uns
natürlich ein szenario das wir vermeiden
wollen und wir tun alles dafür dass dass
es nicht so kommt in italien gibt es in
einigen kranken sind auch nicht in allen
krankenhäusern es gibt in einigen
krankenhäusern die situation der triage
das wirklich eben nicht genug
beratungsplätze dort sind und die ärzte
dann entscheiden müssen wenn sie noch
beatmen und wenn sie eben nicht beraten
und wir hoffen dass die situation in
deutschland nicht auftaucht und wir
müssen alles dafür tun um die
kapazitäten die man haben
bestmöglich zu nutzen sie haben letztens
einer pressekonferenz gesagt sie würden
ihre expertise nicht nur deutschland
sondern auch anderen ländern zur
verfügung stellen was genau an welche
länder konnte empfehlungen für
österreich also also zunächst mal
tauschen wir natürlich ständig unsere
ideen aus es wird ja auch nicht so sein
dass man immer jeden alles was man tut
es ist vielleicht nicht alles immer die
optimale idee gewesen sein das ist eine
krise die man nicht durch planen kann
wir tauschen uns aus zum beispiel jetzt
bezüglich rezepten wie es darum geht wie
man alte schützen kann was für ideen man
hat wie man zum beispiel wir denken zum
beispiel auch darüber nach wie man
studierende nutzen kann
medizinstudierende die es gibt ja dort
verschiedene je nachdem wie gut die auch
schon ausgebildet sind wie weit sie sind
haben sie mehr fähigkeiten als andere
viele von den studierenden haben auch
schon rettungsdienste vorher gemacht
sind krankenpfleger gehäusen oder so wie
können wir die einsätzen noch für
arbeiten die sie normalerweise nicht tun
würden die die die unterstützung im
ausland also sieht ist in diesem bereich
sehr intensiv wir haben aber auch das
wissen sie vielleicht seit dem ersten
januar des letzten jahres haben wir ein
zentrum für internationale
gesundheitsschutz jahr am robert koch
institut eingerichtet und ein hauptziel
dieses zentrums ist es dass wir in
drittstaaten und ein schwerpunkt liegt
er sicher in osteuropa und im auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent dass wir in
drittstaaten mit dazu beitragen wollen
dass dort bestimmte kapazitäten erhöht
werden und wenn sie jetzt an diese
epidemie oder die an die pandemie jetzt
denken dann sehen sie es ist ja
unheimlich wichtig zwei dinge das eine
ist das ein gesundheitssystem
leistungsfähiges und da müssen wir uns
nichts vormachen es gibt viele länder
auf der welt wird das natürlich nicht
der fall ist und das zweite ist dass
dieser sogenannte öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst wie es bei uns heißt
das der auch in der lage ist ebenso zu
arbeiten also fälle früh zu erkennen die
agnostiker zu machen
sie nehmen alle war das diagnostik ein
wichtiger punkt ist und uns einen
hinweis zu geben wieviel fälle dort sind
und wie wir handeln müssen und zu machen
wir in ich nehme ein paar beispiel in
ruanda oder sudan oder
nigeria oder die elfenbeinküste so haben
wir projekte wo wir dort zum 1
die labor kapazität erhöhen auch
ausbilden wie man die laborgeräte eben
benutzt und wie man das vernünftig
einsetzt und ein zweiter aspekt der für
uns unheimlich wichtig ist und das ist
gerade auch bei dieser krankheit wieder
so wir sehen leider oft dass es
infektionen in krankenhäusern gibt das
hat zwei fatale folgen das erste ist
natürlich im krankenhaus liegen ja nun
die wohl haben also die schwachen der
gesellschaft die krank sind und die
werden natürlich unter einer krankheit
infektion auch bei denen verläuft dann
positiv also wahrscheinlich schwieriger
schwerer als bei gesunden
das zweite ist das natürlich auch das
krankenhauspersonal sich anstecken kann
und dann fällt das aus das ist ja auch
eine ressource die wir benötigen das
heißt der zweite aspekt den wir wo wir
uns sehr bemühen ist wenn man das
infektionskontrolle infektionsprävention
und kontrolle und das ist ein unheimlich
wichtiger bereich weil im krankenhaus
wenn in krankenhäusern infektionen
staaten dann betrifft das sehr sehr
viele das war zum beispiel wo hahn auch
mit der anfang der epidemie das zunächst
eben das krankenhauspersonal gar nicht
wusste dass eine infektionskrankheit
dort ist und dann haben sich viele
menschen angesteckt am anfang natürlich
viele nosokomiale infektion und wir
müssen das chaos personal nicht nur
schützen damit es eben selber nicht
erkrankt sondern wir müssen erkennen und
da sehen wir in deutschland auch wir
haben in deutschland auch rund 20.000
tote jedes jahr durch
krankenhausinfektionen
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass im
krankenhaus professionell
infektionsprophylaxe gemacht wird und
all das was wir dort lernen dass wir
lernen ja auch wir lernen auch von
anderen ländern also ist ja auch klar
also dass tauschen wir aus dass hinzu
programme die wir im ausland fahren
das machen wir zur zeit auch und das
machen jetzt teilweise mehr über
videokonferenzen zum beispiel wenn wir
bestimmte module machen und so als sie
das vorher gemacht haben aber das läuft
natürlich weiterhin im ausland auch
momentan
noch eine frage stellen darf ich hab
gelesen es gibt medikamente die für
andere krankheiten eingesetzt
hier wirken unter anderem eine aids
medikament stimmt das wirken die schon
und wie groß die chancen dass man da
wirklich bald was wirksames findet ja
also ich weiss folgendes es gibt ja also
zunächst mal ist es so ja es ist es gibt
untersuchungen mit medikamenten 1 gegen
aids caleta heißt das sind 1 gegen
malaria chloroquin das sind studien die
sind aber nach meinem wissen noch nicht
wirklich belastbar ja also wie gut das
wirkt das weiß man noch nicht aber es
gibt ein anderes medikament randy sie
wir das ist ein medikament das das ein
bestimmtes protein von dem von diesen
viren hemd und da gibt es hinweise dass
das eine wirkung hat was zurzeit
geschieht ist es gibt in deutschland ja
den sogenannten stark ob das ist dieser
ständige ich kann die ständige
arbeitskreis für besonders kontaktlose
zur behandlung konnte dieser patienten
haben wir in deutschland eine großartige
experte sind und sieben kliniken die die
das sind sehr professionelle ärzte die
sich also mit hoch konnte diesen
patienten befassen die diese gruppe wird
die geschäftsstelle gruppe ist am robert
koch institut und wir haben mit denen
zusammen sorgen wir dafür dass klinische
studien gemacht werden
ich glaube das hat fängt jetzt an oder
im april am ersten april von studien an
meines wissens an drei deutschen klinik
wo dann so was getestet wird und ich
glaube das revier ist eines der
medikamente was da getestet wird und
dann wird man sehen ob das hilft also
ich bin sehr optimistisch dass wir damit
auf jeden fall eine verbesserung erlangt
wie gut das ist wie stark das wird
werden wir sehen
es gibt aber hinweise darauf ob wir
dürfen eben nicht dann auch so
zeitungsschlagzeilen oder so glauben
wenn man im labor mal was gefunden hat
das ist immer noch hoffnungsschimmer das
heißt ja nicht dass es dann wirklich
auch richtig wirkt aber wir hoffen dass
ein anderes medikament campus tat dann
ist gerade letzte woche eine publikation
von einer arbeitsgruppe unter stefan
pohlmann vom primatenzentrum in
göttingen erschienen
an dieser publikation waren auch
mitarbeiter des robert koch- institut
als auch
christian drosten beteiligt dass auch
ein medikament das zumindest in der
zellkultur also im labor etwas geholfen
haben das sind natürlich medikamente die
man in so einer krise dann unter einem
kompendium untersagt also leise
patienten versuchen wird und wir möchten
hat gerne natürlich dass das solide
klinische studien sind damit nur eine
aussagekraft haben und solche studien
werden in china zum beispiel auch
durchgeführt
darum hoffe ich dass wir da bestimmte
medikamente haben diddy diddy therapie
einfach erleichtern studie
da das kommt auf die fallzahlen an das
dauert natürlich wochen lang das ist
klar
und die frage ist wie schnell sie ein
ergebnis haben das kann ich nicht sagen
aber es ist auf jeden fall der richtige
weg und darum ist es auch wichtig dass
eben gute wissenschaftler diese studien
machen damit die sauber sind es gibt von
der wehr
da gibt es richtlinien zu heute dass da
sind da sind eigentlich die die die
rezepte liga am tisch das muss umgesetzt
werden die wehr hatte auch eine große
rolle und wir haben eben eine große
rolle dann in deutschland dabei da
hinten
schönen guten tag mein name ist robert
green vom nachrichtenblock teilnehmer
herr müller sie sagten das ist über das
ist völlig normal dass es zu natürlich
solchen von 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung kommt das ist eine zahl die
hat rosten eingeworfen hat in der
diskussion er hat sie aus den britischen
medien von einem experten der sie zum
zeitpunkt geäußert hat als die
ansteckung in china noch extrem hoch
gegangen sind beim jahres wurde auch
eingedämmt hat eine ähnliche
reproduktions zahl wie das neuartige
corona virus also warum geben sie jetzt
auf andere länder teil waren zum
beispiel haben 48 49 gemeldete fälle
liegt direkt neben china geschaffen die
eindämmung auch warum geben sie jetzt
auf und riskieren dass millionen bei
200.000 in deutschland am ende sterben
werden weil sie die eindämmung nicht
fortführen und die zweite frage in dem
zusammenhang laut infektionsschutzgesetz
haben sie sogar die aufgabe infektion zu
verhindern und nicht eine gelenkte
durchseuchung durchzuführen also wer hat
ihnen den auftrag gegeben
hier keinen weiteren an infektionsschutz
durchzuführen
der erste komplett das ist eine
interessante frage die ich überhaupt
nicht verstehe ich glaube sie haben mir
nicht zugehört und zwar seit wochen ich
weiß gar nicht wie lange machen jetzt
das briefen der 200 wochen wie dämme
nein ich will das noch mal klar sagen
wir dämmen ein wir nennen das eindämmung
wir verfolgen
kontakt ketten wie er ich habe gerade
eben noch jetzt vor 30 minuten gesagt
dass die gesundheitsämter jeden fall den
sie entdecken nach vollerfolgen jede
infektionskette unterbrechen wenn sie
das können solange sie das können und
ich habe auch gerade gesagt dass wir das
in allen phasen dieser epidemie machen
ich finde das bedauerlich dass sie dass
sie sagen wir geben auf wir fahren alles
was möglich ist tun wir weiterhin in
diesem land und vor allem die
gesundheitsämter und die erste um das
ein zudem möchten wir ganz klar sagen
dass einzudämmen
zusätzlich zu der eindämmung und das
habe ich auch gerade gesagt die wir die
ganze zeit machen werden
also solange wir die npd bau in unserem
land haben werden wir die eindämmung
maßnahmen weiter mit aller kraft durch
klar zu sagen
zusätzlich zu dieser eindämmung muss man
aber klar verstehen dass es nicht
möglich ist diese krankheit aufzuhalten
sondern wir müssen sehr langsam fuhr
langsam die dadurch dass wir einzelne
ausbrüche eindämmen und verhindern dass
sie sich weiter ausbauen zusätzlich zu
dieser verlangsamung müssen wir die
alten und hochaltrigen menschen und die
risikogruppen schützen und zusätzlich zu
dieser eindämmung müssen wir die
kapazitäten in den krankenhäusern
hochfahren weil wir das virus nicht
aufhalten können wir können nur seine
verbreitung verlangsamt durch ein
dämmungsmaßnahmen ich war wie so können
sie das nicht aufhalten ich glaube es
gibt jetzt wäre wieder hat ausführlich
geantwortet habe noch eine frage bitte
zu den mund nasenschutz masken das ihrer
website schreiben sie dazu dass nur
kranke personen dass es einen sinn macht
zum verhindern von fremd ansteckungen
das kranke person diese maske tragen
mittlerweile ist der aktuelle stand zum
saas koch 2 virus dass er auch ohne
symptome dass menschen ohne symptome
ansteckend sind
das heißt warum aktualisieren sie dann
nicht die information auf ihrer webseite
und geben der bevölkerung eine
möglichkeit an die hand andere nicht
anzustecken es bringt ja nichts dass
alle ins home office gehen und sich dann
im supermarkt anstecken und anhusten im
gang
wenn man dann ein ganz einfacher
mundschutz vor die nase hängen kann weil
wir jetzt hier mit einer
tröpfcheninfektion zu tun haben selbst
cooper empfiehlt mundschutz selber zu
basteln also sie können auch nicht
vielen dank für die frage es ist kein
statement von ihnen sondern eine frage
die haben sie gestellt die haben sie
gestellt dass andere länder auch in
taiwan jeder bürger bekommt zwei masken
pro woche warum sagen sie sind bürger
die mit der anlage fertig danke schön
unter wähler kann darauf antworten
also ich möchte noch mal
darauf folgendes antworten es gibt das
was das robert koch institut empfiehlt
beruht auf wissenschaftliche evidenz
wir empfehlen dinge die wissenschaftlich
belegt sind und bewiesen sind und sie
suggerieren damit dass alle menschen
einen mundschutz tragen einen schutz der
nur in einer bestimmten situation
gegeben ist
der schutz ist dann gegeben wenn sie mit
einer infizierten person die hustet und
niest in engem kontakt sind und wir
müssen dafür sorge tragen dass die
menschen die mit den kranken in engem
kontakt sind also insbesondere natürlich
die ärzte aber auch die menschen die
selber infiziert sind und symptomatisch
sind und das virus aus scheint
symptomatisch ausschalten dass die keine
anderen anstecken beziehungsweise
menschen im gesundheitswesen geschützt
werden und es ist einfach so wenn sie
draußen als mensch mit einer maske
rumlaufen suggerieren sie ein schutz
davor aber es gibt keine evidenz dafür
dass dieser schutz gegeben ist
es gibt drei länder machen ihr tests per
modem auf den erreger um eine valide
remote ali teetz rateteams um eine
valide hre mobilitäts rate zu bekommen
halten sie das für deutschland auch für
sinnvoll
ich gehe davon aus dass wir dass wir die
mehrzahl der an corona virus
verstorbenen patienten auch wirklich
diagnostizieren
dadurch dass wir ja schon vorher sehr
häufig tests durchführen
ich denke dass das für die berechnung
der mortalitätsrate ausreichend ist es
wird aber leider auch so sein wir haben
ja eine über rechner eine sogenannte
über sterblichkeit jedes jahr das tun
wir ja für influenza und für influenza
ist es so dass wir im nachhinein
berechnen können auch menschen die die
nicht getestet wurden positiv getestet
worden sind als über sterblichkeit das
wird bei corona wir uns auch eine
statistische größe sein die wir
ich habe noch mehr bayern hat zum schutz
besuchsverbot in alten- und pflegeheim
lassen
halten sie das bundesweit für sinnvoll
ja also ich will das noch mal sagen wir
haben ja weiß nicht mehr genau wann auf
unsere website solche maßnahme
eingestellt also kannst du mal sagen wir
wir empfehlen ja bestimmte maßnahmen die
entsprechenden behörden vor ort müssten
ja dann die entsprechenden anweisungen
geben wie damit umgegangen wird
das ist eine sehr sinnvolle maßnahmen ja
das ist das was ich beschreibe als
protection als schutz der alten
hochhaltigen und der chronisch kranken
genau das sind sinnvolle maßnahmen zu
denen wir auch schon die bevölkerung
aufgerufen haben schützer kritisieren
dieser maßnahmenkatalog für pflegeheime
vom rk ii aus dem jahr 2013 ist ja hat
das was mit den zeitpunkt zu tun oder
stimmen die maßnahmen immer noch naja
natürlich stimmen die maßnahmen immer
noch wir sind dabei das ständig zu
aktualisieren ist es werden auch dort
aktualisierte maßnahmen erarbeitet wir
wir passen das regelmäßig an aber auch
hier noch mal unsere aufgabe ist es ja
nicht nur das mit den entscheidern vor
allem mit den fachleuten zusammen
abzustimmen die die verhältnisse in den
einzelnen pflegeheim und so weiter am
besten kennen wir müssen ja die
maßnahmen die wir empfehlen die müssen
auch sinnhaft sein und viele maßnahmen
die man vielleicht als bürger einfach
als sinnhaft den sinn ist vielleicht
nicht das heißt wir müssen das schon gut
überlegen welche maßnahmen wieder trend
schreibt und die aktualisierung ist
natürlich regelmäßig in der folge arbeit
moment heute haben ja mehrere
bundesländer angekündigt saarland bayern
berlin und niedersachsen die schulen
flächendeckend zu schließen was halten
sie von dieser maßnahme kommt das zum
rechten zeitpunkt und wie finden sie das
dass die anderen bundesländer das noch
nicht gemacht haben also wenn wir davon
sprechen dass wir die ausbeutung
verlangsamen rollen dann ist natürlich
schulschließungen ein gutes mittel also
wir haben ja selber ich will das auch
noch mal sagen da gibt es ja auch von
uns empfehlungen zu dass man eben
veranstaltung ab sagt dass man kriegt
wir haben kriterien dazu geschrieben
weil man etwas ab sagt und was man für
kriterien nehmen sollte um eine
veranstaltung ab sondern natürlich sind
das auch wirksame maßnahmen wenn man
schulen schließt aber und das ist auch
der wichtige punkt den ich immer wieder
betonen diese epidemie geht hier nicht
einfach von jetzt von nordwesten nach
südosten durch unser land sondern sie
wird in verschiedenen regionen zu
verschiedenen zeiten einfach auftreten
und insofern ist es natürlich sinnvoll
wenn die einzelnen bundesländer und die
einzelnen regionen dass nach der
gegebenheit ihrer lokalen regionen
machen unter anderem natürlich nach der
epidemiologischen situation das ist
schon wichtig es ist ja auch klar wir
reden ja hier über eine epidemie die
noch viele wochen und monate durch unser
land geht und man kann bestimmte
maßnahmen muss man sich natürlich
überlegen wie lange man sie fährt weil
man sie wieder aufhebt und natürlich das
sind jetzt entscheidungen die jetzt gar
nicht so viel mit dem infektionsschutz
unbedingt zu tun haben sondern sie
müssen dann natürlich auch jemanden
haben der die kinder betreut und so
weiter und das ist ja auch ein thema das
glaube ich gestern mehrfach in der
presse angesprochen wurde worüber sich
andere auch geäußert haben das
gesundheitswesen ist sehr weiblich sind
sehr sehr viele kräfte im gesundheitlich
im krankenhaus sind frauen die auch
teilweise eben kinder betreuen
sie müssen natürlich dann auch dafür
sorge tragen dass die kinder eben
betreut werden und dass die menschen
weiterhin zum beispiel krankenhaus
arbeiten können und da müssen sie ihre
konzepte entwerfen wie die kinder
betreut werden dass das muss ja jeder
vor ort selber entscheiden da kann es ja
keine regelung geben von
zentralistisch oder so sondern da muss
man entsprechende regeln finden wie man
damit umgeht thomas mahler von
ard-aktuell die redaktion hat mit der
frage mit gegeben vielleicht ist es
schon beantwortet worden
herr widersprach einmal davon dass
kroner vermutlich eher wie eine schwere
grippewelle wird und sind
schulschließungen dafür wirklich
verhältnismäßig naja also noch mal was
ist eine schwere gruppe
ich will noch mal sagen dass wir ja im
jahr 2017 2018 sind ja rund 25.000
menschen gestorben
an dieser schweren das war eine schwere
grippe und da sind ja sehr viele schwer
krank gewesen auch ja also dass die das
sind ja nur die die todeszahlen der war
eine sehr sehr viele schwerkranke und
damals hat dass das gesundheitswesen
geschafft also da waren genügend
beratungsplätze da und wie gesagt wir
wissen nicht genau wie schlimm das wird
wir hoffen dass es so ist dass das
gesundheitssystem diesen stresstest
überlegt darum heute schlagen wir die
ganzen maßnahmen vor die ja dann die
hospitäler durchführen müssen
schulschließungen sind natürlich eine
maßnahme die sinnvoll ist um das
ausbreitung zu verlangsamen
es gibt allerdings ein aspekt der
bedacht werden muss wir haben ja
pandemiepläne in deutschland und diese
pandemie pläne haben sich bislang
ausschließlich um influenza bezogen weil
das nach der meinung von allen
fachleuten ist die höchste
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein influenza
pandemische virus um die welt geht und
ich will sagen es gibt zwei drei typen
die zurzeit unterwegs sind
die auch so ein potenzial prinzipiell
haben das heißt eine influenza-pandemie
ist nach wie vor nicht auszuschließen
für die zukunft aber es gibt eben ein
paar unterschied und das ist wichtig
dass das eben von von fachleuten
bewertet wird
der eine unterschied ist der den ich
auch mehrfach genannt habe gegen
influenza gibt es ja impfstoffe das ist
ja eine maßnahme gegen influenza die
haben wir zurzeit für corona nicht
dadurch muss natürlich ein plan schon
anders gestrickt sein das zweite ist
gegen influenza gibt es ja auch
medikamente diese neuraminidasehemmer
wir sind ja auch teil des
pandemieplans die zumindest frühen phase
etwas bewirken können die gibt es ja
momentan auch noch nicht bei corona
virus das heißt also auch der korona
virus pandemieplan wird natürlich
angepasst wenn es dann in impfstoff
geben wird und therapeutikum aber es
gibt ein aspekt der ist sehr sehr
wichtig zu verstehen und zwar dieses
virus und das ist der große unterschied
zum saas virus vor 17 jahren verbreitet
sich viel leichter
wir wissen seit etwa fünf wochen glaube
ich dass das virus sich ganz stark in
den oberen atemwegen vermehrt sehr sehr
stark vermehrt also teilweise sehr hohe
virus lasten die in einer höhe wie wir
das kaum jemals von einem virus gesehen
haben und dadurch verbreitet sich das so
leicht und da dass ich es aber auch so
dass im gegensatz zu influenza
da spielen kinder kleine kinder eine
sehr sehr wichtige rolle bei der
verbreitung von der krankheit also
klassischerweise stecken kinder sehr
schnell ältere menschen an großeltern
zum beispiel bei corona stecken kinder
natürlich auch großeltern anja um das
klar zu sagen also ich sags ja das ist
wirklich alters verteilt jeder kann
infiziert werden und jeder kann auch
jemand anders anstecken aber bei
influenza ist es eben so dass kinder
eine extrem wichtige rolle spielen und
nach allem was wir heute wissen ist es
so dass das bei der korona virus nicht
so stark der fall ist das heißt also
schulschließungen haben natürlich ein
effekt alle massenansammlungen wo viele
menschen auf engem raum sind die man
nicht durchführt haben einen effekt aber
der effekt den schätzen wir nicht als so
stark ein wie wir es bei influenza tun
wegen des mikrofons damit die zuhörer
ihre frage verstehen
hier möchte man diese schulschließungen
weil sie sagen irgendwie das hängt dann
davon ab wie es in welcher regierung hat
diese dieser virus verbreitet ist das
heißt wenn jetzt bayern saarland und
anderen bundesländern das ankündigen ist
es doch ein wenig politischer
aktionismus der auch mitschwingt ich
möchte noch mal sagen wir haben ja seit
seitdem wir das hier
analysieren oder sechsten januar sind
wir im institut damit befasst
vierzehnter januar haben wir es
hochskaliert seitdem sind wir sehr
intensiv in den analysen führen experten
untersuchung durch dies und jenes und
ein system was für etabliert haben was
sehr sehr wichtig war weil die
definierung von risikogebieten muss noch
mal sagen was ein risikogebiet ist also
ein risikogebiet die meisten von ihnen
nehmen das wahrscheinlich einfach nur
war anhand der zahlen aber ich möchte
noch mal sagen das ist ja nur ein
ausschnitt
das ist nur ein teil der wahrheit aber
als epidemiologe und kliniker und
virologen ein großes team von leuten die
es bei uns im haus damit befassen kann
man dann natürlich einschätzen aus
vielen erfahrungen die wir haben also
erkrankungshäufigkeit ist ein merkmal
für ein risikogebiet dynamik der täglich
gemeldeten fallzahlen ist ein merkmal
ein risikogebiet was gemacht wird in dem
jeweiligen risiko ist also wie stark
versucht wird das ein zudem wie stark
die quarantänemaßnahmen sind ist ein
indikator aber ein ganz wichtiger
indikator ist natürlich auch wie viele
fälle aus dem risikogebiet werden
anderswohin exportiert das ist eine
matrix so eine art algorithmus der uns
dazu leitet etwas zu einem risikogebiet
zu nennen oder nicht
und jetzt gucken sich an wir haben das
vorletzte risikogebiet wenn ich das
richtig in erinnerung habe war südtirol
das für benannt haben und das kurz ich
war es ja elsass lothringen und rhodos
ja ich kann kein französisch und das
heißt also ist natürlich klar dass dann
bundesländer die mit solchen
risikogebieten er näher an solchen
risikogebieten liegen dass die natürlich
dann auch eine andere risikoeinschätzung
haben als als andere länder ja das sind
alles faktoren die man berücksichtigen
muss
jetzt noch mal dass sie haben davon
gesprochen und als ältere menschen zu
schützen sagen wir ja auch die besondere
risikogruppe sind jetzt gibt es ja
personen die haben ältere leute zu hause
die vielleicht gepflegt oder unterstützt
werden müssen man selber weiß nicht ob
man die krankheit schon in sich trägt
man könnte jetzt zu den corona test
stellen gehen da hat man aber auch die
angst dass man sich denn dort ansteckt
gibt es dann irgendwie ein verfahren das
entwickelt wird um das schnell
herauszufinden was vielleicht auch die
hausärzte bekommen wo man dann im
geschützten rahmen sich testen lassen
kann ja also es werden immer mehr
immer mehr ideen entwickelt also wie das
so ist in so einer krise zeigt sich doch
dass sehr viele menschen sehr
einfallsreich sind ich gebe ihnen ein
beispiel aber es gibt viele andere
beispiele auch die wir auch sammeln die
wir eben auch dann zusammenstellen und
und zum beispiel mit den das sind mit
den kassenärztlichen vereinigungen sowas
besprechen die er für die versorgung
zuständig sind und das finanzieren
müssen und so es gibt zum beispiel ein
modell
ich weiß nicht in welchem landkreis das
ist irgendwo in baden württemberg ich
habe mich genau im kopf wo es zum
beispiel es gibt wie drive ins ja also
wo gezielt personen informiert werden
und gebeten werden dorthin zu kommen und
dann getestet zu werden wir und dann
eben ihre ergebnisse entsprechend
bekommen es gibt empfehlungen das haben
wir auch selber mit anderen kolleginnen
kollegen vor einigen jahren evaluiert
natürlich gibt es auch die möglichkeit
dass menschen sich selber testen ja da
gibt es hinweise da gibt es videos wie
man das tun muss damit das eine gute
qualität hat das ist auch möglich das
sind modelle die teilweise auch gefahren
werden so dass sie davon ausgehen können
dass an sich die die vielzahl der
möglichkeiten für einen speziellen fall
also das was was nicht passieren darf
ist dass jeder sich einfach testen
lassen will weil wir damit natürlich
auch eine kapazität verbrauchen das muss
schon eine indikation dafür sein dass
man sie getestet werden soll und wir
geben dafür ja auch hinweise was eine
integration ist dass das immer weiter
steigt und dass man dadurch immer mehr
wissen hat darüber über den
infektionsstatus aber ich will auch noch
mal sagen es wird ja auch immer mehr
menschen geben also vier von fünf die
diese infektion durchgemacht haben ja
und und diejenige die positiv getestet
sind und die die krankheit überstanden
haben wissen ja dann auch dass sie mut
die können dann zum beispiel vielleicht
auch andere aufgaben übernehmen als sie
es vorher hätten tun können das ist
alles wichtig dass diese information
geteilt wird und das ist eben das auch
was wir sagen dass wir natürlich auch an
jeden einzelnen appellieren dass er mit
so einer situation umgeht also wenn
jemand zum beispiel die infektion
durchgemacht die moon ist dann kann er
vielleicht bestimmte aufgaben übernehmen
die anderen nicht übernehmen können die
letzte frage inzwischen mehr über die
haltbarkeit des virus oberflächen ja das
ist immer wieder eine frage
natürlich kann sich so ein virus je
nachdem wie das wetter ist und die
klimabedingungen kann ich das halten ein
paar tage aber du bist so ein paar tagen
aber das spielt für die verbreitung
nicht die rolle ja das ist der
entscheidende punkt für die verbreitung
spielt die rolle die tröpfcheninfektion
also wenn sie jemandem gegenübersitzen
der krank ist und sie an hustet das ist
der entscheidende weg der vorbereitung
die anderen wege sind diesbezüglich
irrelevant und in dem zusammenhang
nochmal die allgemeinen hygiene
anforderungen oder wünsche die werden
alle äußeren händewaschen lange noch
hände waschen dann ist ihre hand sauber
und dann ist ja auch nichts in
französisch metern also sie selber
können durch die hygiene husten und
niesen in den arme können sie die
verbreitung dieses virus wenn sie selber
infiziert werden wirklich mit verhindern
dann bedanken uns jetzt ganz herzlich
doch eine fortgeschrittene zeit herr
wille hat noch zehn minuten zeit
[Musik]